hey guys it is just under the 16th today
my name is just Mitchell and you're
watching games but me Microsoft are
making another xbox one price cut happen
but this time it's the sign up the
console has been pulled down in price by
the equivalent of about 80 us bucks to
make it more competitive with the ps4
which is coming to the region in a month
the xbox one without connect retailed
for 3699 gone which is about 600 US
dollars and now it's down 500 gone to
the equivalent of 517 US dollars the
xbox one plus connect is slightly more
expensive down from the equivalent of
six hundred and ninety-four dollars to
614 US dollars in China both models come
with at least two free games although
those games are powerstar golf and
neverwinter online so make your own call
about the value of that one rockstar
have finally announced that GTA Online's
long-awaited heists are coming rockstar
games have described the feature
explaining high school require tight
communication and coordination with
players taking on specified roles at
each point to accomplish multiple
objectives on the way to each heist epic
finale the payday sounding edition will
also bring on you gameplay clothing
vehicles and weapons if you want to see
for yourself you can check out the full
announcement trailer in all it's bazooka
toting safecracking goodness on gamespot
so no one's great surprise controversial
Massacre sim hatred has been pulled from
steam greenlight by valve valves
marketing director Doug Lombardi told
Eurogamer based on what we've seen on
greenlight we would not publish hatred
on steam as such will be taking it down
champions of gore and tastelessness
creative destruction who are making the
game won't be deterred though they've
said their overjoyed at the response
from supporters and still plan to
release in q2 of next year hatred
gathered over 13,000 up votes on the
service and hit number seven on the top
a hundred list after only a few hours as
for your question of the day let me know
if you play hatred and why or why not if
you're after more news you can hedge
against block the stories on Microsoft's
wounded game streaming service and the
announcement of sniper ghost warrior
three that's it for me today i'll be
back same time tomorrow with a bunch
more new so I do hope see them